the gondolas are moored up
the ancient waterways of venice usually
teeming with traffic
are quiet now just a few people wander
through some of the most famous squares
and narrow passageways in the world
the city and the rest of the country
remain in covid lockdown
the dark and quiet streets of venice
though are now home to a growing
controversy
over the world's lack of preparation for
the pandemic
at the center of it is this man and his
employer
the world health organization
early last year italy was the epicenter
of the covet outbreak
weeks ahead of the rest of the developed
world dr francesco zambon
was tasked with sending a detailed plan
to all nations
on how to cope based on italy's response
he did it it was published then it was
withdrawn by the world health
organization
the world never got the plan
they could have had what we didn't have
time
we didn't have time to prepare but
this report would have allowed them to
buy
time which was the by far the most
important uh
good uh for getting better prepared for
the pandemic
the chaotic scenes of overwhelmed
hospitals in northern italy prompted the
who
to provide real-time analysis to help
governments prepare
italy was not unique in being unprepared
most countries were not
the report team discovered that italy's
pandemic plan
hadn't changed since 2006 and noted it
dr zambon and his lawyer say it wasn't
an issue until wh
officials told the zambon team to amend
the report
and say the plan had been updated he
refused
and has resigned dr zambon says the
affair has completely undermined
the world health organization's
reputation
i think that the problem here is about
the lack of independence
a lack of transparency of the world
health organization
the mandate of the organization is to
preserve to promote the health
of the citizens of the entire world and
the story that happened in a year
shows that the organization is bound
by personal interests by
government's interest and by
financial powers
100 miles or so west of venice is
bergamo
one of the worst hit cities in the
pandemic
prosecutors are investigating the
government's covid planning on behalf
of the families of those who died here
they've asked for the who
to help their investigation but so far
it has refused even saying staff members
have immunity from questioning it's left
the prosecution teams confused and
suspicious
and talking to dr zambon
disappeared
politico
responding to our questions the who said
that the report
was published too early and it had
inconsistencies
and inaccuracies they did however say
that they are reviewing what assistance
they can give
to the prosecutors here in bergamo
[Music]
dr zambon is now unemployed and has been
forced to put his home and his beloved
piano up for sale
the prosecutors in bergamo say his
testimony and any evidence he possesses
continues to be part of their
investigation
preliminary findings of that
investigation are expected next month
stuart ramsey sky news northern italy